lors de notre second débat je vous
propose d'analyser les conséquences de
la septième vague de kobe dans notre
système hospitalier à bout de souffle
avant d'entendre nos invités les
chiffres qui caractérise cette nouvelle
flambée épidémique avec sandra série à
l'épidémie de kovy de repart en flèche
selon le ministre de la santé deux cent
mille cas positifs ont été recensés en
24 heures avec plus de 1600
hospitalisation un chiffre qui n'avait
plus été atteint depuis la fin avril en
déplacement hier au centre hospitalier
de créteil françois braun a appelé les
français à la responsabilité face à la
septième vague de qu'ovide associés aux
sous mario micron hautement contagieux
en fait deux ans et demi pour être vite
je pense que les gens ont compris le
message et sabre nos concitoyens que
quand ils sont dans des lieux clos au
cidre et des moyens de transport bien
c'est plus prudent de mettre le masque
c'est prudent pour soi c'est surtout
prudent pour les autres donc c'est ça le
message principal
le sénateur et l'ère alain milon dit ne
pas comprendre pourquoi le gouvernement
se limite à émettre des recommandations
sans annoncer de mesures plus
contraignantes ya des millions de gens
qui vont prendre les transports en
commun donc il ya des millions de gens
non vaccinés ou peut vacciner ou pas
assez vaccinés qui vont attraper le coc
vide et sur les millions il ya
obligatoirement des gens qui font des
formes compliquées est urgent de
vacciner deux protégés de mettre les
masques tdd les services d'urgence au
maximum pour l'instant à l'hôpital le
rebond reste modérée mais avec un pic
épidémique est attendu fin juillet début
août bon nombre d'infections la auxonne
l'alertent c'est pas une c'est pas une
ride alerte banal c'est une réalité nous
avons déjà des rêves des restrictions de
personnel pour les vacances celui que
comme d'habitude à c'est la même
rengaine il va commencer à descendre
mais l'impact à l'hôpital va se faire
sentir deux fois plus puisque moins de
personnel le conseil scientifique
prévient qu'il faut s'attendre à de
nouvelles vagues de co vide et souhaite
que le pass and i ter soit rétablie aux
frontières si la situation sanitaire
l'exigé j'ai de son côté le gouvernement
a assuré qu'il n'y aurait pas de passe
vaccinale dans le futur projet de loi
sanitaire
je vous présente mes invités tout de
suite je peux vous dire que ça discutait
déjà pendant le reportage de sandra
cercle héra véronique guillotin bonsoir
du soir vous êtes le médecin sénatrice
centriste de la meurthe et moselle vice
président de la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat bernard jomier bonsoir
il est aussi médecin sénateur apparenté
ps de paris et vice-président également
de cette commission des affaires
sociales patrick pelloux bonsoir à tous
et bienvenue vous êtes le président de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france et lætitia cloud pas et rester
à mes côtés on est donc en plein dans sa
danse est 7ème vague avec cette
information révélée par le nouveau mini
de la santé françois one cet après-midi
deux cent mille cas ces dernières 24
heures véronique guillotin cette
septième vague en préparant les missions
je me dis c'est pas possible je suis en
train de prononcer ces mots est ce que
vous imaginiez les prononcer un jour
vous aussi si on remonte deux ans mais
même si voilà vous savez ce que c'est
vous vous n'êtes pas épidémiologistes
mais vous saviez ce qui pouvait se
passer mais ce que vous imaginez un jour
dire 7e boys bon j'imagine est qu'on
allait avoir d'autres vagues oui je suis
pas excessivement surprise que ça
revienne donc oui voilà après ils font
prendre des mesures on connaît mieux le
virus il faut être à la fois savoir que
ça revient une vague c décontamination
10 et enfin le variant est relativement
contagieux peut être pas plus grave mais
c'est quand même des personnes âgées qui
vont aller rentrée aux urgences à voir
leur médecin traitant certains - est
hospitalisé on sent aujourd'hui le
frémissement hospitalier donc moi j'ai
toujours c'est comme le lait qu'on a sur
le feu aujourd'hui et il faut être prêt
à réagir rapidement
bernard jomier quelles sont les
caractéristiques de cette vague c'est au
médecin que je m'adresse là avant de
parler un peu plus politique ce nouveau
variant il est plus ou moins contagieux
par rapport aux autres
voilà dit le lait sur le feu la
caractéristique surtout cette épidémie
c'est que depuis le 1er janvier la cette
année 23 mille morts donc ça fait
quarante à cinquante mille cent l'année
40 à 50 milles c'est le nombre de morts
en gros de l'alcool du tabac de la
pollution de l'air c'est à dire les
principaux problèmes de santé publique
dans notre pays où vous dire l'ascension
la banalisation quoi abbas et on voit
bien que c'est le brouillard total c'est
à dire que yao répondait pas à ma
question faire de la politique
c'est qu'on a un problème majeur de
santé publique qui est en cours et comme
réponse à ce problème majeur on a pour
le moment on va y venir mais un
brouillard donc c'est ça la situation
après le ce que produit tel ou tel sous
variant vous savez après le bep à 5 y en
aura un autre ça commence déjà en inde
le 2 7 5 je crois tiens donc oh ça va
être une succession de soirée ont donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment est ce
qu'on prend en charge ce qui est un
problème majeur de santé publique
patrick peloux le taux d'incidence visé
ça tout à l'heure 1200 cas sur cent
mille personnes testées c'est ça on est
à quel niveau journée on y voit où ça
allait en fait irruption comparses il ya
par rapport à il ya un an on aurait eu
jean castex qui serait venue sur son
pupitre il aurait expliqué les mesures
vers encore et soutenu les mesures du
gouvernement et on aurait remis le pass
sanitaire des mesures de restriction etc
qui était qui était nécessaire je pense
que c'est je pense que c'est un virus
éminemment sociale et politique en fait
parce que il joue des tours etc a en
effet complètement d'accord le
l'épidémie est pas près de s'arrêter on
ne sait pas du tout où on va on ne sait
pas du tout où on va on ne sait pas quel
variant va arriver en septembre
a priori à une saisonnalité ça arrive
printemps automne il ya un truc comme ça
qu'ils jouent en effet il ya il ya des
variants qui sont en train d'arriver ce
qui n'a pas un variant qui va se pointer
et qui va réussir à craquer le vaccin là
ça serait vraiment catastrophique comme
dit bernard jomier il ya déjà eu 23
mille morts las en ré du faire la une de
tous les médias etc ah là là c'est
totalement banale d'accord et c'est
vraiment un problème est là ce qui est
étonnant c'est que le ministre de la
santé parle du masque et tout le monde a
oublié le gel hydroalcoolique et à l'ena
ne va pas sans l'autre parce que vous
vous frottez en moyenne une trentaine de
fois le visage donc d'un coup vous
transmettez comme ça ben vous apercevez
que sur les terrasses des cafés le gel a
disparu c'est entrer des centres
commerciaux il a disparu et c'est
dommage et un dernier point c'est que en
fait on a fait une erreur on va on a
fait une erreur je pense qu'il ya eu une
forte de la part d'olivier vers ans
quand il a quitté son poste de ministre
où il a dit allez le masque terminé
c'est fini fayard une certaine euphorie
ce que je comprends un peu cheap oman
par moments donc du coup il s'est libéré
mais en fait non le virus continuait et
ça a prolongé le truc en allemagne le
masque est obligatoire des transports en
italie aussi en espagne aussi au
portugal c'est une vraie question
valable l'évacuation et vacances
commencent sur sur cet aspect politique
c'était aussi avant l'élection
présidentielle oui c'était sous toujours
le prétexte qu'ils annonçaient que bien
sûr laetitia de la question je vais vous
poser maintenant c'est elle concerne
emmanuel macron est ce qui peut
finalement
gouverner la france mais imposer la même
politique sanitaire face à cette
septième vague c'est toute la question
comment emmanuel macron gouvernerait
tyloo va-t-il gouverner on n'y ait plus
de liant dit lionel voilà avec une
assemblée qui n'est plus à ses ordres
est ce qu'il y aura toujours ces fameux
conseil de défense sanitaire objet
politique non identifié a pas de
fréquence on ne savait pas qui a été
dans ces conseils totalement opaque on
n'a jamais su qui étaient autour de la
table on savait qu'ils avaient emmanuel
macron puisque c'est lui qui décide et
in fine est alors pour essayer de
comprendre ensemble c'est l'objectif de
cet édito et répondre à cette question
je vous propose de réécouter bruno
retailleau sénateur a l'air de vendée
qui c'était le 1er avril 2021 avec les
autres chefs de file de l'opposition au
sénat avait boycotté le vote sur les
nouvelles mesures sanitaires le
gouvernement voulait que nous votions
sur rien sur des mesures que il aurait
été demandé à nous et au sénat de
prendre alors qu'elle était déjà prise
alors à quoi bon voter ainsi déjà tout
était décidé une pensons que le sénat
comme le parlement comme l'assemblée
nationale c'est pas une chambre
d'enregistrement ça n'est pas un lieu
d'une fausse concertation ou d'un
simulacre de décision et nous avons
voulu le dire solennellement au chef du
gouvernement d'autant plus que ce
gouvernement a des pouvoirs extrêmement
étendue mais qui sont concentrés dans
une seule main celui d' emmanuel macron
qui décide de tout et c'est une critique
on a entendu peut-être pas au tout
départ mais très rapidement dans la
bouche des députés et des sénateurs qui
dénonçait cette gouvernance ultra
centralisé qui quand même concerné le
quotidien de tous c'est à dire que le
confinement a été une mesure décidée par
l'exécutif et a concerné l'ensemble des
français alors c'est pour cette raison
que je m'interroge aujourd'hui comment
emmanuel macron va-t-il gouverner avec
une assemblée encore une fois qui n'est
plus à ses ordres est ce que le
parlement aura un pouvoir de nuisance et
pourra peut-être orienter différemment
la politique sanitaire de nuit ou de
rééquilibrage on peut employer ce terme
là véronique guillotin et est-ce que je
rebondisse ou ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure de jeu mais est ce que
finalement l'exécutif a pris la décision
début janvier d'arrêter je mets des
guillemets d'ennuyer les français
avant avant les les quatre élections qui
se profilent à l'horizon les quatre
tours d'élections qui se profilait je
sais pas si c'est un virus politique et
sociale comme ça a été dit en tout cas
c'est en tout cas c'est un virus moi je
regrette les postures politiques dans
ces temps de crise enfin voilà on est on
est quand même dans une situation
compliquée je crois que personne sauf un
en tout cas en personne ce leurre on est
dans une crise sanitaire avec ses
rebondissements
aujourd'hui on affronte on affronte une
septième vague et je crois qu'il va
quand même falloir faire preuve de 1,2
raison d'objectivité et de mesures fin
voilà aujourd'hui on est durs sont très
différents des mesures le le traitement
politique pour reprendre un peu ce que
disait des cercles pas l'instant est pas
du tout le même à 6 mois l'intérieur oui
alors je sais pas alors déjà au début je
enfin faut quand même se remettre dans
le contexte au début c'était quand même
un virus qu'on connaissait absolument
pas donc on a eu effectivement le le le
enfin il fallait tous enfermés chez soi
pour on a une masse qu'on savait pas si
la doctrine du masque était la bonne ou
pas la bonne fin voilà on a quand même
pas mal tâtonné je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on est plus dans cette situation là et
je regretterai forfait en tout cas moins
quand tu auras des mesures je les vois
très à l'aune de des mesures
scientifiques à l'aune des connaissances
que l'on a et de la raison aussi parce
que je crois qu'il faut aussi
responsabiliser les gens qu'on en
entendait parler du mas oui les masques
le lavage des mains les aérations le gel
hydroalcoolique ça ça doit quasiment pas
quitté en tout cas notre vie facile
filles vous le savez est par exemple les
heures comme ça pour sortir de chez soi
équipes à pied qu'il fallait si j'ai
bien mangé la restriction des libertés
j'aurais tendance à dire non mais si si
des mesures plus restrictives de v de v
se profiler jeu ouais je leur mettrais
oui bon mais moi je vous entends dire ça
je me dis pitié enfin on peut on va il
faut bien qu'on apprenne à vivre avant
oui il ya un ça c'est sûr mais oui on
sait on va pas continuer ce qu'on
finisse et ceux signés
6 et papiers pour dire je vais faire le
tour de mon quartier juste peut-être
pour terminer oui il faut apprendre à
vivre avec mon un deuxième problématique
qu'on va quand même voter aujourd'hui on
a quand même problématique de l'accès
delà des soins des personnes qui
risquent d'être contaminées un virus
quand on a 40 ans si on n'a pas ce souci
c'est rien mais quand j'entends dire
faux démesurément augmenter les places
de réals coup il faut aller en rire moi
je préférais enfin je vais faire quand
même que les gens n'aillent pas en rire
parce que vous savez aujourd'hui mieux
que moi mais un patient qui en réa pour
un cowitz est dramatique et du coup on
savait pas donc je crois qu'il faut
quand même avoir les deux oui à mon avis
sous la loupe bernard jomier là on va
faire de la politique est ce que veut le
gouvernement a manqué d'anticipation où
finalement a sciemment décidé de mettre
un peu le l'épidémie sous cloche parce
que parce qu'il y avait les élections
qui arrivent et oui bien sûr il a
abandonné toute toute pédagogie si on
peut dire de l'épidémie à partir au mans
la séquence électorale commencé c'était
le discours d'olivier ferrand et puis la
programmation d'ailleurs qui allait avec
de l'abandon des différentes mesures
alors ceci dit épidémie on n'est pas
dans la même situation qu'en 2020 c'est
plus l'heure des mesures restrictives
parce que on a une protection collective
n'est pas parfaite mais une faute à une
protection je parle pas d'immunité mais
par le vaccin ça c'est le premier enjeu
il faut maintenir cette protection dans
le temps or depuis le début d'année vous
avez vu des campagnes d incitation de
fans il faut qu' on est à 20 25 %
seulement des plus de 80 ans qui ont
fait deuxième rappel les chiffres sur
les dramatiques à 25 5% des
66 avant ses impressions de plus de 80
dans les hôpitaux il décès etc
deuxièmement
l'appropriation par la population des
enjeux de l'épidémie et notamment des
questions d'intérêt général vous savez
dans une dans une épidémie à notre
interindividuelle pis il ya l'intérêt
général la protection qu'on se doit les
uns des autres a été totalement
abandonnée il n'y a plus de discours sur
cette question là donc quelques choses
simples comme quand on prend le métro
moi j'ai en métro porter son masque on
est 20 % dans le métro a pensé le match
là là là cet après midi avait 20 % mais
oui c'est ça enfin ce matin quand j'ai
pris le métro on était voilà à peine 20%
c'est apporter un mas pourquoi parce que
il n'y a pas de discours sur notamment
une gestion oui mais on a aussi écrit
quelqu'un d'ouvert dix ans on
infantilise les
et là il appelle à la responsabilité et
on y arrive il n'y a plus du conseil
scientifique s'est terminée n'existe
plus et on ne sait pas comment va se
faire le dispositif de veille et
d'allergies interroger la première
ministre la semaine dernière et elle m'a
répondu de façon tout à fait franche et
honnête et c'est tout à fait à son
honneur on y réfléchit bon mais ça dit
bien pourquoi quand même conseil
scientifique parce que de par la loi il
se termine avec la avec la sanitaires
locaux 31 juillet s'est terminée du
conseil scientifique il est
automatiquement dissous et donc on ne
sait pas comment va être conseiller
qu'est la vivent et publiés comment être
un ferment et l'afrique ce qu'est ce que
vous attendez là vous attendez quoi
comme vaut plus rien en fait ça je suis
pas d'issue
non non on peut juste plusieurs points
moi ce que j'attends c'est justement un
engagement de de santé publique est en
effet comme bien dire bernard si vous
voulez on peut toujours faire des
incantations en ahl code de la route on
pourrait toujours espérer que tout le
monde respecte le code de la route ban
on a toujours besoin des gendarmes et
des policiers sur les routes peut
évidemment et des radars bon voilà on
est comme ça on est un peuple qui est
vaillant courageux et disciplinés on l'a
vu quand il ya eu confinement tout le
monde a dit oh là là ils vont jamais
respecté tout le monde à respecter en
fait on n'a pas eu sur les voies sans
ben oui mais ce qu'attendaient les gens
et je pense que le ministre de la santé
a tort il s'insère pas grand chose de
dire les gens sont responsabilisés ecsta
parce qu'en effet comme vous venez de
dire il y en a que 20 % dans les
transports qui vont porter le masque est
donc vous êtes dépendant est tributaire
et puis il suffit que vous soyez à
quelqu'un à côté de quelqu'un qu'il
l'est pour vous avez le ramener à votre
part en plus âgée et ça va être la
catastrophe donc ça je pense que c'est
le premier point cessé ils ont tort de
part est imposée le masque bon tant pis
s'ils choisissent ceux qui sont au
pouvoir ils choisissent deuxièmement
pour répondre à véronique sur les lits
de réanimation
ce qu'a révélé cette cette crise ap
j'en ai parlé x fois avec jean castex et
il était d'accord c'est qu'en fait on a
tellement diminué les lits de
réanimation on est toujours sur le fil
qu'en fait s'entraîne quoi alors ça
dépasse le coc vide ça entraîne que d'un
coup on fait une sur sélection des
malades qu'on va mettre en réanimation
ça ça va pas du tout les aime c'est à
dire que d'un coup moi je le vois quand
on quand on bosse en réa quand on bosse
au samu et qu'on appelle pour dire on
veut mettre tel ou tel malade on dit
alors qu'elle antécédents l'extérieur je
pense qu'on a trop diminué le curseur de
l'accès à la réanimation et aux actes
réanimatoires cinq mille cinq cents lits
de réanimation sur la france dom tom
compris pas en fait vous apercevez que
d'un coup il ya ipso facto une sélection
qui est fait donc du coup il ya une
volonté avant qu'il parte jean castex a
dit il fallait monter de plusieurs
milliers de lits de réanimation mais je
suis tout à fait d'accord je craque en
fait les lobbystes qui sont contre ces
je comprends même pas qu'on soit content
l'arrêt augmentation des lits de
réanimation soit dit en passant mais bon
il y en a un ça va ça va poser problème
est donc là en effet il faut pas
chercher vous parler fort justement de
l'accès aux soins moi ce qui me fait
peur à l'heure actuelle c'est comme j'ai
vu dans le journal de la sarthe qu'on
m'a envoyé ce matin où on dit vous ne
pouvais plus aller aux urgences vous ne
pouvez plus appeler le samu qu'est ce
qui va rester aux gens termes de
sécurité du rôle régalien de l'état et
je sais que c'est le discours du
ministre de la santé de dire il faut
plus aller aux urgences mais si vous
enlevez ça aux françaises et aux
français comment ils vont avoir un accès
aux soins parce que on je comprends tout
à fait la montagne de faut gravir pour
améliorer l'accès au soin mais vous
pouvez pas tout enlever aux françaises
et aux français parce que là vous parlez
de l'égalité des chances de l'intérêt
général de l'hôpital public service
public et c'est vraiment dramatique quoi
on reviendra si vous le voulez bien sur
cette question l'état de notre
hôpital public je voudrais qu'on termine
sur la question des réponses
gouvernementales à cette septième vague
et je propose à quand un calme et de
nous rejoindre avec ce tout premier
texte quand un rebond soit examiné en
séance au parlement alors son titre
officiel je vais vous le donnez projet
de loi de maintien provisoire d'un
dispositif de veille et de sécurité
sanitaire en matière de lutte contre le
kobe de 19 à la ce que l'on a à dire
donc je les ai mises en place
effectivement on est au milieu d'une
septième vague mais c'est un paradoxe le
gouvernement décide d'une lente et
progressive sortie de crise c'est ce qui
se dessine avec ce projet de loi le
conseil scientifique alors avant
qu'effectivement il ne soit complètement
voilà à nu les églises où paressent
dissous merci il a rendu un avis positif
le 23 juin dernier médecin et
épidémiologiste se réjouissent je cite
de ce retour vers une normalisation
annoncé mais prudente exit par exemple
la possibilité de rétablir l'état
d'urgence sanitaire pas de passes
sanitaires ou vaccinale pour restreindre
l'accès à certains lieux ou
rassemblements non plus on parle d'un
très court projet de loi avec seulement
deux mesures la première c'est le
maintien jusqu'au 31 mars 2023 d'un
dispositif de veille contre locaux vides
19 concrètement les fichiers
informatiques cidep pour les tests et
sivac pour la vaccination seront
prolongées saveurs et de suivre
l'évolution de l'épidémie deuxième
mesure le gouvernement se laisse la
possibilité de mettre en place un pass
sanitaires aux frontières
écoutez olivier van alors non plus en
tant que ministre de la santé mais porte
parole du gouvernement steffen
un autre article propose aussi si la
situation devait l'exiger c'est à dire
en cas de nouveaux variants par exemple
de pouvoir rétablir un système de passes
mais un espace aux frontières ou entre
le territoire métropolitain et les outre
mer
le texte a été adopté hier en conseil
des ministres il arrive en séance lundi
à l'assemblée nationale et si tout se
passe bien dans l'examen de ce texte au
sénat le 20 juillet prochain merci
quentin guillotin est-ce que
effectivement il n'y a pas une espèce de
danty climax soit 2,2 contre courant la
dent dans cette politique mais moi je
serais plus je serai plus radical que ça
serait plus radical que ça oui je pense
qu'il faut rien lâcher enfin c'est pas
le moment de lâcher les choses et c'est
décevant que toutes les mesures ont
parlé tout à l'heure mais même
l'information je crois que les gens sont
perdus même quand on est professionnel
de santé oms dit bah oui ball masque
c'est pas obligatoire mais c'est pas
pour moi moi j'ai voilà j'ai pas 75 ans
donc non je pense qu'il faut des mesures
il faut annoncer des mesures claires
c'est à dire le masque et soit
obligatoire dans tel endroit conseiller
dans telle autre tel âge et les vaccins
moi je suis un peu effaré aujourd'hui
par la non campagne de vaccination voilà
nos personnes âgées aujourd'hui c'est
eux qui souffrent qui risque d'avoir des
pros des complications et on voit là on
sort fait la bise tous on sait plus trop
si on checke si on voit donc je pense
qu'il faut remettre aujourd'hui c'est
largement le moment d'informations sur
la 4e dos ben oui où il faut vacciner
pour relancer la vaccination des
personnes les plus âgées les plus et les
fragiles et celles qui ont des
comorbidités ça c'est quand même urgent
de ce groupe fait la 3e et concernant le
pass le pass sanitaire moi j'y suis pas
opposé quoi je me dis que si quand il ya
des grands rassemblements des espaces
clos des espaces fermés voilà quoi il
faut il faut qu'on se prémunissent alors
si c'était un oeil médical moi je vois
là mais oui parce que c'est quand même
une sorte d'état d'urgence sanitaire
pendant combien de temps le prochain jeu
je suis bien conscient que des risques
et je minimise pas les risques quand je
vous entends les uns et les autres et
j'entends vos avis
nico mais si je me place la plus tôt et
on a eu beaucoup de constitutionnalistes
sur ce plateau sur la question de la de
cet équilibre entre la santé libertés
publiques pendant combien de temps on va
rester dans un système privatise de
certaines de nos lecteurs pour air et un
temps que c'est là longtemps
on va aussi dont on doit remettre des
mesures un peu plus intrusif sur un
temps court et peut-être par secteur il
faut tête mais c'est un coucou pour lui
sectorise c'est exactement c'est en fait
c'est un compromis il à dire que on peut
pas quand on est responsable sanitaire
en france dire il ya une épidémie on est
déjà comme disait bernard jomier 23
mille morts depuis début janvier puis
dire bah finalement faites ce que vous
voulez faites ce que vous voulez ça veut
dire qu'en en effet on en a tous
complètement d'accord à tous ras-le-bol
moi je ne veux absolument pas qui à
nouveau de confinement la vie économique
et surtout culturel
éducatif doit être relancée de ça c'est
évident mais je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord mais ça veut dire des
précautions et en effet sur des trucs
simples ce que font nos journaux nos
amis allemands italiens s'est réaffirmée
choses et je pense que les français le
comprennent et ça permettra on le sent
bien quand vous prenez le train il ya ce
qu'on le masque et qui sont voilà et
puis vous avez ceux qui ont palmas alors
il ya un côté retors comme ça ou d'un
coup ils veulent ils veulent montrer que
ccc c'est dommage et c'est vrai que si
oui on est tourné dans des des médecins
autour de cette table moi j'ai vu
tellement de gens mourir et qui
soi-disant avait aucun antécédent et ccc
ccc triste et il faut relancer toute
cette mécanique si vous la relance est
pas bah en fait la population va pas
comprendre et en effet vous délaissez le
truc alors après en effet faut vivre
avec tout à fait d'accord mais à ce
moment là faut assumer complètement la
mortalité avec si on est déjà 23 me ça
veut dire qu'au mois de décembre s'il ya
un nouveau à riom en sept sites web on
voit là on va avec 80 mille morts de
plus on entendre de deux prises de
parole d'abord sur la vaccination est
ensuite sur le port du masque sur la
vaccination pour commencer je vais
d'abord vous redonner les chiffres on
les a vus rapidement tout à l'heure mais
je pense qu'ils sont très importants
taux de vaccination avec la deuxième
dose de rappel pour ceux qui sont
éligibles on est à 25 5 % des 60 79 ans
et à 31,3 % des plus de 80 ans donc on
est vraiment très très loin des
objectifs et on écoute alain fischer qui
est professeur d'immunologie
pédiatriques président du conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
il regrette évidemment ce relâchement
écouter aujourd'hui pour les personnes
fragiles donc les personnages et plus de
60 ans et les malades ça fait quand même
globalement 15 20 millions des français
c'est ce qu'il faut donc environ une
vaccination tous les 6 mois sachant
qu'une infection beaucoup de personnes
ont été infectées jouent à peu près
l'équivalent déclenché à peu près
l'équivalent en termes de protection
unes les autres pour les pour les autres
non je voulais dit tout à l'heure il n'y
a pas d'indication pour l'instant de
deux rappels ensuite on peut penser
qu'on a on entre quand même dans un
système où liée plutôt des
reconnaissances saisonnières ce qui
n'est pas le cas actuellement et que
plausiblement un rappel annuel suffira
avec la grippe bernard jomier moi ce que
j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre les
réticences qui existent encore sur la
vaccination et oui faut pas on est à des
chiffres aussi bas j'ai bien entendu
parler c'est une campagne d'information
pas assez d'eux c'est le prénom d'un thé
ses multiples comités le conseil
d'orientation la stratégie vaccinale
qu'at-il dit en mars at il dit en avril
qu'at-il dit en mai qu'at-il dit en juin
rien voilà donc j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour alain fischer mais à un moment il
faut arrêter
cette politique est une politique de
gribouille total où on décide de ne rien
faire et on se réveille en disant ah oui
depuis quelques semaines ça remonte il
va falloir faire quelque chose il ya
trois grandes mesures à prendre
rapidement et pas moi je le dis le texte
contrairement à vous je pense moi je
suis plutôt d'accord avec le texte qui
est proposé je pense que le pass
vaccinale de sanitaires n'est pas n'est
pas adapté d'ailleurs je n'avais pas
voté en janvier et je concède qu'il n'a
pas eu d'impact sur la dernière vague de
l'épidémie je ferme cette parenthèse
mais un une campagne vaccine massive de
vaccination je suis d'accord avec vous
il faut maintenir une protection pour
deux un vrai plan d'aération et de
ventilation des locaux clos c'est là où
ça se passe très majoritairement c'est
indispensable
et troisième troisièmement il faut
absolument qu'on ait une vraie pédagogie
du masque peut-être une obligation dans
les transports mais en tout cas déjà une
vraie pédagogie du mas et du gène on n'a
pas ces discours la mairie n'a rien on
n'a rien eu pendant des mois donc
l'opinion publique est persuadé que
c'est terminé si on lui disait est ce
que vous savez que c'est une des trois
principales causes de mortalité dans
notre pays le coc vide personne n'y
croit plus ils iront oui l'année
dernière mais pas en 2022 c'est c'est
terminé donc comment voulez vous portez
une politique de santé publique quand
les responsables de cette politique sont
aux abonnés absents alors il ya une
autre démonstration sur le masque c'est
la prise de parole de jean françois
delfraissy qui est encore président du
conseil scientifique c'était le 30 juin
dernier sur rtl on est passé d'une d'une
période d'injonction
recommandé très fortement etc ou obliger
à maintenant à une recommandation et je
suis pour cette attitude de et le
conseil scientifique en général pour
cette étude de recommandation donc il
paraît là aussi assez logique pour les
personnes les plus âgées les plus
fragiles en particulier dans des temps
des lieux de promiscuité dans les lieux
dans les transports en commun dans les
transports en général de reporter le
masque oui je le recommence je le fais
moi même quand je prends le métro
donc là on est le 30 juin donc c'est il
ya peu de temps on peut la situation on
a bien vu là on a deux sur mille cas en
24 heures véronique guillotin on met à
la veille des premiers grands départs en
vacances la sncf a annoncé qu'elle
allait battre des records de
fréquentation
historique donc brassage de population
fin tout ça le connaît par coeur
pourquoi il n'ya pas le message de
d'obligations jeu j'ai entendu
l'argument que je donnais tout à l'heure
sur infantilisation pas sans
responsabilité des français ou pas mais
là on se dit c'est pas très compliqué je
pense que ce serait acceptable de la
part des français et puis faut un
message clair en fait c'est le message
est pas toujours tout n'est pas blanc et
noir enfin pourrait dire dans tel type
de rassemblement dans tel endroit dans
les transports en commun c'est sûr qu'on
va peut-être oublié le truc où il ya le
trot dans la raquette mais je crois que
les gens ont besoin de clarté c'est
compliqué à comprendre c'est un des
français sont pas tous médecins
infectiologues et ses terrains donc je
pense qu'il faut effectivement des
messages clairs moi je serai aussi
favorable au port du masque et depuis
je vous interromps de le dire on vous
fait confiance on joue sur votre
responsabilité manifestement ça ne
fonctionne pas ça n'est pas suffisant
donc là il faut une injonction qui ont
leur fille coincée c'est pas qu'on veut
n'a pas confiance qu'ils n'écoutent pas
je pense que les gens sont perdus je
pense qu'ils ne savent pas quand il faut
le mettre quand il ne faut pas le mettre
et quelquefois alors je moi je dis pas
que c'est infantilisant je pense que le
message clair il est pas infantiliser il
ya des moments où il faut dire voilà les
conditions pour que ça se passe bien il
faut pas obliger dans tel endroit et
puis voilà on va peut-être le garder
huit jours de trou et jour deux mois
j'en sais rien enfin après on va pas
regarder la couleur du carrelage comme
on dit mais je veux dire il faut à un
moment donné huit des messages clairs et
sur le mas et sur la vaccination maj
insiste vraiment sûr sur le schéma
vaccinal parce qu'on s'est quand même
que c'est ce qui protège et l'aération
effectivement sur les endroits les
endroits clos il ya 3 4 messages forts à
passer à répéter et à remettre en boucle
sur nos chaînes et le gel
hydroalcoolique et les lavages de mains
que jeanne sûr on va les affiches et y
aller légère parce qu'on fait aussi un
peu de pédagogie les messages de
prévention une consigne je suis sûr que
vous allez suivre en régie on va les
voir s'afficher se laver fréquemment les
mains aérer régulièrement les espaces
clos porter un masque dans les lieux de
promiscuité les espaces clos et en
particulier les transports en commun se
tester dès les premiers symptômes et
s'isole immédiatement en cas de
positivité vérifier son schéma vaccinal
allez il reste un peu moins de dix
minutes voilà dans ce dans ce débat et
on va parler maintenant de la situation
de l'hôpital vous l'avez évoqué déjà
tout à l'heure avec déjà l'impact de
cette énième vague septième vague sur le
nombre d'hospitalisations voilà les
chiffres que nous donne le ministère de
la santé chiffres du 1er juillet seize
mille hospitalisations dont 960 en soins
critiques me l'hospitalisation par jour
en moyenne + 31 %
au cours de la dernière semaine par
rapport à la semaine précédente et on va
écouter rémi salou manqué le président
de la commission médicale de l'ap-hp lui
nous dit pour l'instant c'est gérable
mais compliqué on écoute l hôpital c'est
à la fois gérable parce qu'il ya malgré
tout assez peu de cas graves qui vont
jusqu'à l'hôpital il y en a quand même
et compte tenu là bas j'avais un millier
de patients en soins critiques en france
et à sebha rapport à la première vague
on était à 7000 1 et donc les vagues
suivantes plutôt 3 4 il donc c'est vrai
que c'est nettement moins mais compte
tenu de l'état de saturation du manque
de personnel que je vous ai rapidement
décrit juste avant c'est compliqué et ce
qui est aussi compliqué c'est que le
personnel soignant est aussi touchée
patrick peloux scc la conjonction des
deux qui nous intéresse à dire que ya
peut-être moins d'hospitalisations en
soins critiques mais il ya moins de
personnels pour les prendre les prendre
en charge et ce qu'on est dans cette
situation aujourd'hui le en fait le
titre de votre émission est vachement
bien c'est le sens public en fait ce qui
se passe c'est qu'en fait vous avez les
moyens à l'hôpital qu'ont été érodée en
cours des de toutes ces années et la
crise du coc vide on a eu un espèce de
sursaut voilà ce qu'on voit souvent
d'ailleurs chez les gens en fin de vie
d'ailleurs un et quelques jours avant de
mourir il ya un sursaut comme ça un élan
de vie et puis tout s'est effondré c'est
à dire qu'on a tous cru au célèbre quoi
qu'il en coûte maintenant et puis après
tout s'est cassé la figure et il ya le
phénomène du grand renoncement de la
grande émission démission n'avait pas
cette théorie voilà c'est très vrai à
l'hôpital c'est cesser enfin vous
connaissez vous connaissez tous des des
gens à l'hôpital moi j'ai des collègues
des infirmières qui me dit j'arrête pied
avant vous l'a dit mais tu vas faire
quoi disait arbres je vais faire ça et
ça me va et je pense que je faire
j'arrête c'est c'est terrible c'est
terrible j'étais juste avant de venir
sur le plateau à la commission médicale
d'établissement de l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris et on ne parle que de
ça mais on voit le bateau coulait quoi
littéralement il a c'est vrai on
augmente de 1000 par jour les
hospitalisations va pas tenir très
longtemps comme ça et j'étais de garde
cette nuit pour bah vous avez des
problèmes majeurs pour hospitaliser les
malades avec des accidents vasculaires
cérébraux alors il ya des discours santé
publique disant si vous avez un petit
déficit appelé tout de suite le sas en
disant on va vous hospitalisé mais il ya
plus de place d'accord bon voila et là
du coup vous allez avoir des paradoxes
comme je vous disais de deux journaux de
région notamment la région paca aussi
qu'ils commencent à dire vous ne venez
plus aux urgences vous appeler le samu
etc ça va entraîner des inégalités
d'accès aux soins majeur et vous allez
voir on n'a pas fini de se voir pour des
gens qui vont décéder parce qu'ils
n'auront pas eu accès aux urgences était
un des premiers déplacements des manuels
macron
aux urgences un sont produits à
sarrebourg ça ne servait à rien à rien à
rien et il avait demandé la mission à
brawn qui est devenu ministre et c'est
la mission flash c'était donc un bel et
bien un enjeu politique
ce qu'ils proposent nous on le combat je
le combattrai tout le temps en fait
c'est à dire que pour moi alors il faut
peut-être arrivé en quelques mots ce qui
voit là c'est à dire qu'en fait ils
veulent dire qu'avant d'aller aux
urgences vous devez appeler le samu qui
est déjà débordée donc on va pas pouvoir
faire j'en parlais avec un autre
collègue là qui s'occupe de la libérale
y est de la régulation libérale à paris
me disait on est en train d'exploser et
c'est pour vous pouvez pas faire un une
barrière vous pouvez pas fermer les
structures de gens cela il ya à peu près
entre 50 et 75 services d'urgence qui
ferme la nuit donc du coup l'autre jour
il ya des gens qui sont battus devant
l'hôpital parce que la divergence était
fermé cc c'est pas possible c'est le
sens public c'est l'intérêt général
c'est l'assistance publique et qu'est ce
qu'on va faire de la grande pauvreté des
gens qu'on parle téléphone here on leur
dira ah bah non vous pouvez pas venir
allez-vous-en c'est pas entendable parce
que pour moi c'est le rôle régalien de
l'état est le socle de la république
bernard jaume i est ce qu'il y avait eu
alors comment je peux dire ça est-ce que
c'était impossible de lancer une grande
réforme en pleine épidémie en pleine
pandémie ou est-ce qu'au contraire vous
dites là il y avait là une occasion
parce que tout le monde était centrée
sur ces questions de santé comme vous
dites ya eu 1 1 il ya eu un ressort il
ya une une opinion qui étaient mobilisés
et est l'occasion a été manquée alors
papa pendant les premières vagues le
système de soins était entièrement tendu
par la prise en charge des patients mais
on a passé ce stade là maintenant ça
fait plus de deux ans que l'épidémie a
commencé et on a justement tiré les
leçons fin on sait on a analysé il ya eu
des travaux ici au sénat mais dans
l'autre chambre le haut conseil de santé
publique et c'est donc maintenant
j'allais dire tout est sur la table et
c'est l'heure des décisions et c'est
l'heure des décisions c'est plus lors
des inventaires et des rapports je crois
que ce que le ministre a face à lui
maintenant c'est au delà de cette
mission flash qui est bon dans terreau
est assez limité on va dire mais c'est
que dans les trois mois il doit ouvrir
une négociation avec l'ensemble des
acteurs sur la réorganisation notre
système de sang de santé mais je sais
d'ailleurs les mots employés sont plus
forts il faut sans doute le reconstituer
c'est au minimum des états généraux
voire une constituante parce que
l'hôpital est en difficulté mais le
système de ville aussi c'est l'ensemble
du système qui est en difficulté et donc
il a trois mois je pense pour réunir ces
acteurs pour négocier la répartition
entre la place de l'hôpital public la
place de l'ambulatoire ce qu'on demande
aux uns et aux autres et les moyens
qu'on alloue et le rendez vous c'est au
prochain projet de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale à l'automne soit il ya
les premiers marqueurs parce qu'on peut
pas tout demander de faire comme ça en
claquant des doigts et à toute vitesse
et soyez les premiers marqueurs d'une
vraie prise en compte structurelle des
problèmes de notre système de santé et
on travaillera tous ensemble et les
professionnels retrouveront motivation
naissance parce qu'ils sauront dans
quelle direction va ils seront que si on
passe pas du jour au lendemain de douze
patients pour une infirmière a à nouveau
11 10 et 8 que ça prendra des années
mais ils seront que ya cette direction
là voilà il faut mettre en place ce
dispositif est là à ce moment là on va
pouvoir maintenant début pour le mettre
en mai 6 mai va demander à son
prédécesseur demandé au chef de l'état
et demander au premier ministre
peut-être gtoi en 95
et l harmonie des hôtels
cathédrale d'occasions manquées on parle
je ne dis pas que c'était facile cette
pandémie bon ben voilà inscrite pendant
la guerre les joints sur le principe
bernard schmid dans la crise je vois pas
comment enfin les conditions dans
lesquelles on travaille et on venait on
était confiné enfin je vaux de la santé
donc c'est assez dur de la santé il ya
quand même eu un il ya eu une volonté de
faire quelque chose en pensant que de
mettre l'argent sur la table suffirait
il devait recevoir la santé publique est
alors le premier graphique l'avait
annoncé il ya eu de larges issa était
arrivé beaucoup d'argent ban en
investissements
mobilisés
il ya eu beaucoup d'argent effectivement
2 me en investissement fonctionnement
des aides aux salaires qui a créé
quelques distorsions ok mais il ya eu
voilà mais il ya eu de l'argent qui a
été mis pour autant on s'aperçoit que
c'est pas c'est pas l'essentiel de ce
qui est attendu et de ce qui est
nécessaire alors chacun apprendra sa
part parce qu'effectivement ça on sait
depuis quand sadate donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ne leur étant dit ça
j'aurais tendance à dire la balle est
bien au milieu et il faut revoir moi je
pense qu'elle profonde il faut revoir le
système de soins dans son ensemble est
ce qu'on voit aux urgences à l'hôpital
c'est il faut revoir et laval et l'amour
il ya aujourd'hui par le grand chose qui
tient vous allez sur les territoires
ruraux ça tient pas vous allez dans les
quartiers de ville aujourd'hui où les
métropoles semble épargner ça ne tient
plus les professionnels de santé sont
découragés les jeunes femmes voilà donc
on a une refonte complète du système ont
fait du soin faudrait faire plus de
prévention il faudrait travailler et me
semble-t-il non sur l'offre parce que si
on recommence chacun dans nos silos le
médecin généraliste le médecin
urgentiste l'infirmière l'aide-soignante
machin travail en silo eh bien on va on
va reproduire ce qui nous a amenés dans
la situation actuelle je pense que le
système ait pu fait pour pour le siècle
dans lequel nous vivons donc il faut
qu'on revoie cette formation il faut
plutôt partir de l'offre partir des
besoins travaillant populationnelle et
faire confiance aux acteurs de terrain
aux territoires lâcher la bride et de
toutes les conditions et les contextes
et les complications administratives que
les que vous connaissez enfin quand un
médecin ou un interne va passer une
heure et demie aux urgent à trouver un
lit qui trouve pas à laisser des gens
c'est pas acceptable le système la
mission flash en disant oui je comprends
quand vous dites et on peut que le
comprendre on ne peut pas fermer la
porte des urgences bien sûr on peut à ne
pas faire accéder mais pour autant
est-ce qu'on peut continuer à laisser
des gens sur des mots patrick peloux
c'est plus compliqué que ça parce que
quand vous regardez ça c'est passionnant
quand vous regardez souvenirs communs
2003 la canicule d'accord vous regardez
ça qu'est-ce qui se disent qu'est ce que
dit ma tei dès que c'est la fin de la
canicule dit on va réguler il faut
appeler le samu on va réguler et tout ça
a fait flamber de 10 millions passage
donc le problème il est ailleurs
problème est ailleurs et le problème il
est dans l'accès aux soins en fait c'est
ça l'important vous avez plusieurs
millions de français ça a été dans votre
dans votre dans notre commission dans
votre rapport qui n'ont plus de médecins
traitants dont probablement que le
principe même du médecin traitant il est
obsolète bon il faut s'intéresser aux
gens il faut surtout je la fin de
l'émission alors je conclue juste par ce
truc c'est que ces médico psycho social
et qui a un lien avoir entre les
services sociaux des communautés
territoire etc et l'hôpital ça ça ne
fonctionne pas du tout et notamment dans
la prévention des personnes âgées le
vieillissement à domicile merci de vous
être adapté aux formations c'était la
conclusion en orbite on aurait pu
continuer c'est vrai que ce titre a été
très bien à trouver c'est perrine
tarneaud la directrice dans la foule qui
l'a trouvée donc on peut lui rendre
hommage après tout c'est son job mais
c'était une belle trouvaille parce que
c'est un très beau titre ce sens public
y en aura pas demain figurez-vous parce
que demain c'est la journée spéciale
discours de politique générale
d'elisabeth bornes joue